Now let's help our users find our app
and get some organic traffic for free.
We can do this by search engine
optimization, or SEO for short.
We can also do the same
thing in the App Store,
which is called App Store optimization,
ASO.
>> How does it work?
The search engine uses an algorithm that
scans all of the information on the web
and for app stores, the algorithm
scans all of the information in
all listings of the App Store.
The algorithm will decide
what is the most relevant
based on the content of your site and
the most relevant sites and apps
will appear at the top of the results
but under the paid ads of course.
Let's talk about some of the techniques
you can use for SEO and ASO.